Every single one of the websites in
front of us was built using AI and every
single one of them looks like AI slop.
The same boring layout, gradients, and
same stock components. But, this website
here was also built out using AI, but
nobody would have guessed that. And the
difference isn't the tool, it's eight
techniques that nobody bothers to use.
My name is Jono. I've built two
seven-figure businesses and I've also
designed over 50 beautiful websites.
[music]
And today I'm going to be walking you
through every single one of these
techniques so that by the end of the
video, you're going to understand how to
build beautiful websites using Claude
Code that do not look like AI slop.
Let's head over to technique number one,
which is giving Claude Code the right
instructions. Now, every single project
in Claude should have a Claude.md file.
These are just instructions we're
telling Claude in order to behave the
way we want it to behave. And
specifically, the only thing that
actually matters here really is this
paragraph here. We're just telling it to
behave like a senior UI designer and
front-end developer. And surprise, it's
going to go ahead and act like a senior
developer. Now, let's head over to
technique number two here, which is
finding inspiration from websites that
we already love. Now, you can go ahead
and ask Claude to find beautiful
websites for you and that's exactly what
I did to find Railway here. And I
genuinely really love this website. I
think it looks beautiful. So, technique
number two is about cloning a site like
this. Now, just to kick things off, I
put in this prompt right over here to
build out a standard website. How I got
this was I typed in what is Railway. I
gave it a description to Claude of what
Railway was and it went ahead and built
out this really um generic and average
at best website. But, what we can do is
supercharge this by copying Railway. How
we do that is by taking a screenshot
over here of the site, okay? And then
we're going to use a prompt just like
this. And essentially, what we're saying
in this is actually go to railway.com,
analyze the website. It's going to be
able to actually detect all of the HTML,
CSS, everything that actually goes into
building this and then essentially clone
the entire thing. I'm also going to
attach a screenshot so that it can
visually see exactly what we are seeing
ourselves. So, I'm going to go ahead and
send this off and I'm going to return
back in a matter of a couple seconds
when it's done. Cool. So, everything's
good to go. We've cloned Railway here
and let's take a look at the results.
One thing I'll point out here is that I
did copy their image, okay? I downloaded
and used it in my file. And here are the
results. Right away, first shot, it's
looking already absolutely beautiful.
So, that's a very good way to be able to
clone or replicate a website that you
truly love online in a matter of just a
couple minutes. Another place to draw
inspiration from is also a site called
Dribbble. So, in here, we can type in
something like website
just generically, I guess. Just website
does the trick. And it will give us
designs that other people have put
together. So, if for example, you like
this particular website right here, we
can go ahead and looks like this is
actually a video, but we can pause it
and we can take a screenshot of this
website and then use that as inspiration
as well. And of course, there's a lot of
websites out there like this. Dribbble's
not the only one, but this is one of the
sites that I use very frequently to find
inspiration for user interfaces. Okay,
so let's move on to technique number
three over here, which is all about the
actual underlying technology that we're
using. So, what we're doing is we're
heading back into Claude Code and we're
asking it to build out the site using
something called Tailwind CSS and
Shadcn-ui.
Now, for those of you who do not know
what CSS is, let me give you a 10-second
crash course. It stands for cascading
style sheets. It's just styling on a
website. Here's a website with CSS.
Looks beautiful. This is what we've
built so far. Here's a website without
CSS. In fact, this is actually that
exact same website. It just has no
styling with it. It just has HTML. It
has the text, inputs, images, all that
kind of stuff, but there is no styling.
And so, that's what CSS does and
Tailwind is just a framework or a CSS
library in order for you to style
beautiful websites, but you can do and
and it's just like the low-level
styling. So, you can do things like
padding for example or you can put
width. So, you can have columns on
particular pages, stuff like this,
right? However, if you want to create
reusable templates, this is where Shadcn
comes in. And if we over head over to
components, we can see a bunch of
pre-made reusable templates that we can
use across our website, across multiple
different pages. So, for example, we can
have a professional accordion out of the
box or we can have avatars for
potentially like testimonials for
example or we can have reusable buttons
that we have that we use. That's what
Shadcn does. It's a reusable template
library that we can import into our
project immediately. Okay, so let's head
over to technique number four here,
which is all about backgrounds. I'm
going to pause this video and return
back when we're all set. Cool. So,
everything's good to go and we've
implemented a gradient background. Let
me just be really concise with this.
It's a radial gradient with multiple
different colors, a blurred purple,
blue, and pink and teal circles
positioned around the page, okay? This
is what it looks like. We moved away
from the image on rail railway. And the
beautiful thing is is as we're kind of
scrolling down this project, it does add
a lot of texture and a lot of character
to the site. And what I like about it is
that even though it's a pretty
minimalist site, there's not a lot of
stuff going on here. It still looks
beautiful with this in the background.
It just makes it feel a bit more busy, a
bit more complete or full just by adding
in a background. Okay, so with that
being said, what we're going to do here
is move on to the next step, which is
adding animations onto our website. So,
I'm going to fire off this prompt right
over here and circle back when it's all
said and done. But, we're using
something called GSAP and Framer Motion.
Essentially, what these do is they bring
elements to life. So, let's kind of take
a couple examples of what this looks
like. If we just head over to the site,
you can see all the kind of cool stuff
that you can do. But, here's just a
really basic example. When we scroll
down, we can give animation to all of
our elements on the page so that they
can kind of like flow in and and and all
of that kind of stuff. It looks like
they're flying in, I guess, is the right
word. And then we can also use something
like motion.dev to bring all the
individual elements to life. So, these
are examples of what you can do, but we
can add in things like a toggle for
example and it gives that professional
look where this white dot flips across
the screen. And so, all of those little
tweaks, which I feel like we take for
granted, but are actually kind of
sophisticated and complicated to build
um at least if you're not using AI. It
took me a long like honestly, that was a
huge struggle. I thought these kind of
things would be so easy to build, but
they're actually incredibly difficult.
At least it was for me before AI. And
now in like literally one prompt, you
can build these animations across your
entire website. Cool. So, the site's on.
So, let's take a look at the results.
So, as we slowly scroll down the page,
we can see a lot of motion. And
unfortunately, that's actually clipping
the subtitle down there. So, this is
something that we'd want to change and
we can circle back to that at a later
point in time. But, as we scroll down,
we can see the text and images gliding
in at the bottom here. Right? We can see
again at this stage and the next stage,
we can see the bars and all of this kind
of stuff coming to life all the way down
the page. Okay, so what that is is
that's this GSAP
library right over here that's doing
that. And as we're scrolling down, we
can kind of see it moving. And then for
this motion library right over here,
what this is doing on the page is it's
all the hover hovering effects. So, like
when we click this button or this box
here, it moves up ever so slightly. And
when we hover over this button, it
enlarges. And it enlarges with 300
second milliseconds delay. So, it's not
like instantly popping up, otherwise it
would be kind of jagged and and and
rough. It's really smooth, right? So,
it's happening over 300 milliseconds.
Same kind of deal with these buttons
with the gray background as well. So,
all of that kind of stuff is adding
animation to our website. Now, the next
step is probably actually my favorite
part of designing websites. I think it's
absolutely stunning and that is building
3D
design into a site. So, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to send this off,
okay? And I'm going to tell Claude to
use two libraries. One is called Spline
or Spleen or I think it's Spline. I
think I just horribly pronounced that.
Um and the other one is 3 3.js over
here. So, we're going to be using these
guys. Let's go over what they actually
do. First, we're going to start with
um we're going to save the best for
last. So, we're going to start with
3.js. Now, we can have all of these kind
of motion graphics or sorry, 3D graphics
on our site. So, we can get things like
this moving automatically in the
background. So, if you've ever come
across those sites where it has like
these really cool 3D graphics and you're
wondering how they do it, this is
exactly how they're doing it. And
there's other libraries out there that
do this as well. Another one is Spline.
I hope I got that right. Um and with
this, you can you can grab tons of
different 3D graphics as well. Let me
show you just a couple here that I think
is that I think are really cool. So, we
have this ball over here where it rolls
across the screen with your cursor. Next
one over here, we have this nice little
uh
thing. I don't even know what to call
that. I'm just going to call it thing.
And then the third one here, which I
think is beautiful, is these horizontal
lines coming into the into the into the
fold. And then lastly, we also have this
these 3D boxes that follow where your
cursor is going, which I think is really
cool. Now, what we're going to be using
specifically in this demo is this guy
right here, which I think is freaking
sweet. And it also gives me the same
vibes as like stripe.com over here, how
they have this beautiful nice little
thing in motion. So, very similar feel.
And so, for that reason, we're going to
use this. Now, you do need an account
for spline.design,
and um
but it is free, okay? And so, when we
log in, we'll head over to the community
tab right over here, and you'll need to
actually go ahead and grab this. And
I'll leave this in the description down
below. But essentially, what we're going
to do is we're going to grab this, and
then we can remix this, which means
we're just copying it into our project,
and we're going to edit things. So, I'm
going to click into editing it. But it
actually comes with all this text that I
don't want. And so, I'm going to go
ahead and delete all of this stuff so
that we can get it off the page. This
graphic here, I also don't want. I just
don't want anything where if we zoom out
here, we have your everyday life,
wellness, AI, all this kind of stuff in
the background. Obviously, that's not
going to look good if we have that right
at the top here, right? We don't want
text layered on top of text, because if
we were to import it in just like that,
it would actually legitimately have
that. So, we're good here. We can hit
export in the corner, and then we want
specifically the
um the code export right over here. It's
going to generate a link. We're going to
copy this, and then paste it in. So, I'm
going to say, "Please
use this spline graphic above the fold
for the background."
Okay. And then we can paste it in here,
and it's going to naturally build that
out, include it on our website. Cool.
So, everything's good. Okay, let's go
ahead and demo this out. Here is now our
website with the spline graphic in the
background here above the fold. And when
I say above the fold, I just mean like
literally before you scroll down the
page, this is the first graphic that we
see here. And we can see here that there
is first of all this logo that I
probably should have deleted there.
And you could just go back into the the
graphic and and find that wherever it
is, and then delete it. But also, there
is this kind of rough edge over here. We
could smooth this out with a gradient
over top here, okay? And that's an
option as well. We just have a gradient
that essentially goes from this color to
transparent, so that as we scroll down,
it just naturally fades into this
background over here, okay? So, that's
the spline graphic. And if we scroll
down the page here to the CTA section,
in that prompt as well, we said in the
call to action section, include 3js, and
we can see the graphic right over here.
Now, there is a lot of different
graphics that we can use from 3js. This
is kind of just not the exact one, but
this is more or less what it is that I
asked for to include. By default, a lot
of the times when you use it, it tends
to gravitate towards just like a
standard graphic like this, but there's
a lot of different stuff that we could
build using 3js, and you just can just
you can just tell it exactly what it is
you're looking for. As long as it's
available, it will go to work for you
and build it out. So, that's a cool way
that we can have 3D graphics behind a
particular element on the page, and
those are two different resources we can
call on. 3js down here, and then we can
also call on spline up top here, which
honestly add so much character to the
website, and right away, this really to
me like takes it over the top in terms
of professionalism. Okay, lastly, what
we're going to do is we're going to head
over to the final prompt here, which is
all about typography. So, we'll copy
this prompt into Claude Code. And
specifically, what we're doing in this
case is we're using Google Fonts to find
something that we like. So, if you just
type in to Google Google Fonts,
on the first link here, we can grab from
a whole host of different fonts. And all
of these are free. All we have to do is
reference to Claude Code which one we're
looking for, and it's going to go to
work for us pulling it out and applying
it to the particular website. You can
have one font for headers, one font for
your body paragraphs. And if this is
your first time coming in using Google
Fonts, one of the cool things is is you
can sort by calligraphy. So, for
instance, maybe you want handwriting.
Okay, you can go down the list of all
the different types of handwriting.
Maybe you want something like informal,
you can kind of see some text in that
kind of category. You also have formal,
you have upright, you have all these
different types of fonts to choose from.
So, you can easily
you can easily sort based on the style
it is you're looking for. And when
you've gone ahead and found one, you can
paste that right into Claude Code, or
you could just ask Claude Code, "Hey,
pull out the font you think is going to
be the best suited for the website I'm
building." Sweet. So, everything is
live. Let's take a look at the font over
here. And right away, super noticeable.
Now, I find that with fonts, a lot of
the times it's viewed as like something
that's not necessary, tacked on at the
end, kind of minimal. But honestly, I
feel like it changes the whole entire
look and feel of a website, especially
when you have a nice beautiful font.
Especially as well when you have two
different fonts, one for titles, and one
for body paragraphs. And in this case,
it almost looks like there's three
different fonts, one for titles, body
paragraphs, and then bullet points as
well. And if for whatever reason you're
not happy with it, you can go back to
the drawing board and grab new fonts
from Google Font, and then include it
directly onto your particular website.
Now, the last thing that I want to talk
about in this video is technique number,
I guess, nine technically, where we can
go through the whole website and change
anything that we want to. And how we do
that is through screenshots. I find that
to be one of the most effective ways.
So, instead of trying to describe how
you want to change like a graphic over
here or a graphic over here, we can take
a screenshot. So, for this entire
section, we can literally just grab a
shot over here, and then describe what
we want changed in that particular
screenshot. In this example, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use this
particular grid over here, because it's
kind of bothering me how there's only
one graphic right here. What I'd rather
have is like 4x4 graphics, so it looks a
bit more full. So, I'm going to go back
to the drawing board here. I'm going to
copy this particular prompt, and we are
going to paste it in. We're just
building out that grid system where
there's 4x4 in a row. And I'm also going
to attach that screenshot that we just
took as well. Cool. So, we're back, and
it looks like it's gone ahead and
implemented all of those eight
additional grids into the graphic here
for
>> [snorts]
>> all different services or whatever that
this fictitious company is offering. So,
thanks guys for watching. If you want to
learn more about Claude Code, I highly
recommend taking a look at my
masterclass on the subject for free on
YouTube, and all the blueprints for this
video are going to be down below in the
description for free. If you guys want
to learn more about AI and automation, I
highly recommend first of all to
subscribe to the channel, because if you
like this video, I'm sure you'll like
others. And also, if you want to learn
more, I have a paid AI automation
community where I go through all of this
kind of stuff and teach you how you can
first of all make money with AI and
automation by finding, closing, and
fulfilling your first deal within 30
days or less, and then scaling up from
there. And if you have an existing
business, I'll show you how you can
automate up to 80% of it with blueprints
that you can literally just copy and
paste into your existing business, which
allowed me to personally scale my
businesses to seven figures. And of
course, if you don't want to have to
automate these things yourself, you can
take a look at my agency where we can do
this on your behalf. Thanks guys for
watching, and I'll see you in the next
one. Bye-bye.